all right so um as you came in you
should all have gotten a little piece of
paper um that has your login credentials
for nabari which is our our training
platform that we're going to use today
so if you haven't already gone to this
URL the instructions for how to log in
to naari are at that
URL so we will be logging into the um
the nabari instance and then we will be
get cloning the training
materials so
uh actually let me I can show you what
that looks like so as you go to uh
training. quanite dodev you'll be taken
to this keycloak login
page sure
um we'll talk about nari in just a
second y'all just stick with me all
right so we're going to sign in Via
cloak you have your own um individual
credentials information on your little
strip of paper that's because you're
going to be given your own server so
this tutorial is about big data and Big
Data visualization and the only way to
do big data is with some uh some
machines so we are going to give each of
you an individual server and we're going
to be using dask and we're going to
distribute that work across a lot of
different dask workers in the cloud so
we're going to use our nibari platform
to do that so we're going to log in um
we're going to click medium
instance and now what nabari is going to
do nabari is a an opinionated Jupiter
Hub deployment that has a bunch of
extras and niceties attached to it and
um it's configured in such a way that it
makes deploying a Jupiter Hub deployment
in the cloud running uh running with uh
kubernetes clusters and dask and uh lots
of other things all attached very very
simple so it simplifies a lot of things
so even I who I'm not a devops person I
can deploy nari and then we get a
collaborative Jupiter Hub platform for
your whole team or in this case
everybody in the tutorial so um nari was
developed by uh quanite which is where I
work and um it's an open source uh
platform it's an open source product you
have to deploy it on your own machines
however you like to whether cloud or HPC
systems and so now what it's going to do
is it's going to reach out and tell gcp
hey I need a server and since we're all
doing this at the same time it's going
to take a minute because gcp says wait a
second I'm not going to give you all the
machines at once so it tries to
like give you know it tries to Dole them
out diligently to all the people so it
might take a minute um if we weren't all
hitting this at exactly the same moment
you know in the same span of a couple
minutes this would happen a lot faster
so like when I was testing this earlier
spun right up no big deal but since
we're all hitting it at the same time it
takes takes a
minute sorry are we doing the small
inance or the medium in you can do
medium yeah yes what if you already C
Small you can go to
home uh no you probably can't see home
you can go to
file and um you can't I can't show that
on the screen but you can go to um file
Hub control center I think it's called
and then you can log out you can stop my
server so if you already have a small
you go file Hub control center that
that'll take you to a page that looks
kind of like this and you click um stop
my server and get a
medium and it's going to take a
minute it's taking quite a few
minutes there are too many of
you
[Music]
so while that's
coming
um I will just introduce myself so my
name is Kim Peavey I am a senior
software engineer manager at quanite so
the vast majority of my duties involve
um software engineering and then a
little bit of management of a small team
um at quanite I do a very wide variety
of things I I do um backend data
analytics on Big Data uh all the way
through uh API creation architecting
packages uh to visualization and
dashboarding stuff so I do just a wide
variety of things on a day-to-day basis
um my my original background is in civil
engineering I did a lot of geospatial
work and uh did a lot of numerical
modeling of water resources and um
that's how I got my start in Python and
I thought hey I like this so I switched
to um python
full-time and here I
am and this is is taking
forever so this uh training instance is
deployed on gcp so we're we're actually
um requesting nodes from Google and
that's what we're waiting on we're
waiting for Google to actually give us
individual server nodes for each of you
and it's being very uh dingy at the
moment I'm just going to be patient I'm
be patient you can click the event log
and there's nothing important in here
sometimes it's like it says things that
you might think oh like this
insufficient that it always says that
don't be
scared that's like when it's when it
first ask for a node it's like hey I
don't have any nodes in my node pool
well yeah because you got to request
them
um we'll be patient did anybody get a
node yet
anybody a few a few okay all right cool
so it's coming we'll be patient patient
I want you you do get a node
hey once you do get a node you should
close out all the things that you were
doing right before
sorry pretend
like there we go okay once you get a
node you'll be redirected to uh Jupiter
Hub deployment so this is this is nabari
uh a nabari deployment so now I'm
sitting on my own individual server you
guys are going to have your own server
so we have our own individual server
space and then we have um
uh on aari we have a shared space so if
you wanted to pass a notebook to your
buddy next to you you can do that um but
for today the first thing that you're
going to do is uh through this launcher
interface you're going to go down to the
terminal and you're going to run this
get clone command is at the bottom of
this page so there's a get clone command
to get the training
materials so um on this nabari uh
deployment you have a persistent NFS so
you have a persistent storage here so it
will be here if you log out you log back
in your data will still be there um
however I had no idea how many of you
there would be and so I created just a
bunch of random logins and I didn't
populate your space for you apologies
but so now I need you guys to populate
your own space um so you can get run
this get clone
command and um well that's just the you
but if you run get
clone that'll get the um the
tutorial uh repo for you I've already
done that so I'm going to navigate right
in here and then go to the
introduction
okay now that was a lot of
setup it really wasn't much setup it
just took a long time but that's because
we can't do we we can't uh or we we can
do big data with a lot of different
things but uh our the way that we like
to do big data is with dask and so today
we're going to teach you about doing big
data visualization backed by dask on the
cloud so all of that was required for us
to get some Cloud
resources um I already talked about
myself um what I I didn't talk about is
pavitra she uh is responsible for all
the goodness that is going to be in this
tutorial I mean she's she's done like
the vast majority of the work here uh
I'm just here presenting unfortunately
she could be here today um but she's a
developer Advocate at quanite she's also
part of the bouquet core team um and she
has worked uh extensively with the Das
community in her previous role um and
she's wonderful I wish she could be here
with us but here I am presenting solo um
H let's see what um I think we've
already talked about this we just need
to um you're going to log into nari
you're going to get a medium instance
you're going to uh run get clone and
then the environment that we're going to
be using for today is um called analyst
Pi data NYC
2023 so um one of the benefits that we
have in nabari using um using the the
the platform of nabari that we're all
sitting on is that we have not only do
we have shared storage space we have
shared conduit environments so I've
already created a cond environment for
us to use that's already set up and
ready to
go um so that's the name of
it and
um next there'll be a couple of
exercises that say uh your turn with
little computer guy all right so we're
going to start with dask so the way that
we're going to get to visualizing large
quantities of data is through
distributed computing
and that's going to be done with dask in
the background
so um so we need to start by building up
an understanding of what dask is and um
and also what data set are we going to
work with so um we'll just we'll just
jump right in on the data set I suppose
so for this tutorial we're going to use
the uh Airline ontime performance data
set which is a bunch of flight records
that were created by the US Department
of Transportation Bureau of
Transportation
statistics um basically it's an open
source data set and it covers a uh 1987
to present day and um 23 major airlines
it's just a bunch of flight data that's
um so tells us the flight number the the
tail number of the plane if it was late
if it was early um what time it it flew
lots of different information so it's
really a great data set just to kind of
play around with so we're going to work
on um a subset 2003 to
2022 and that's going to be about 70 gab
on disk so just to let you know kind of
what that looks like on disk this is in
um it's in a gcp bucket um and there's
just a whole bunch of CSV files that's
how the data came to us
so
um now why do we need need something
other than pandas and numpy to analyze
this data um if you were to uncomment
this and run it which don't do that um
you would you would crash your kernel
because it's too much data so the only
thing that this this here is doing is
it's getting the list of CSV files it's
opening up uh data types Json and it's
creating one gigantic Panda data frame
but if you try to create a Pan's data
frame with that much data you're going
to crash your kernel because your uh
current server can't handle that much
data yes question so I actually tried
and and running it then I get a variable
error so in the it's a Le comprehension
file SQL it's asking you what FS FS glob
oh look at that yeah yeah um I'm I might
have accidentally deleted that um FS is
is um it's probably uh GCF
G
gcfs um file system it's some GC SFS
that's right right GC
SFS yes yes um so this is what we're
missing we're missing
um missing basically this from there so
that's it's basically just constructing
a uh a file system object to access that
uh GCS
bucket sorry I must have lost that at
some
point I I can't say that I have run this
recently
um okay so what is dask going to do for
us so dask is going to provide us uh
parallel and distributed computing in
Python so we're going to start by is
talking about parallel Computing so
we're going to take our work that we
need to do our compute and we're going
to distribute that amongst multiple
processors and we're going to do that
through the dask data frame API dask has
several different apis that there's um
the data frame API which mimics Panda's
um data frames and uh x-ray not
xarray dask arrays mimic uh numpy arrays
if you've ever used xarray xarray is on
top of desk array um there's also uh
interfaces for things like lists and
iterators and um lots of other things
but today we're going to focus on the
Das data frame API so that's going to be
very similar to um
pandas so if we if we run this
um so we have a dash data frame as DD so
that'll be
our our function name and then we're
going to call re read CSV just like we
would in pandas but we're only going to
grab out all of the months that end in
beer for now we're going to grab all
sorts of different combinations of this
data but for now we're just going to
grab these four months in
2020 and if we take a look at DDF so DDF
is really commonly used with um with
pandas data frames so you know in pandas
you might typically use the DF variable
we use DDF uh to to denote um dask data
frame a
lot so if we look at DDF what we see is
it is a Das data frame
structure but we don't actually see any
data we
see um we see some metadata about it so
we see the the number of columns we have
or we see the actual columns we see the
number of partitions which is how dask
is going to uh separate out this uh data
structure and then we have um we have Rd
types so what we don't have here is any
data and that's because dask is lazy
it's uh it's not actually going to go
out and do any computations yet it's uh
it's it's going to remain lazy and just
build up the process of a computation
and hold off on running it until we tell
it to
run so it's not until we call compute
that it's going to execute any comp
computations at all so now if we say
Okay um you want to get the uh we take
the
month um column and we we find the
whoops and we find the number of
unique um number of unique values in the
month column if I run that without the
compute we see uh that we have a dask
series object but that's lazy be it's
it's lazy because it hasn't actually run
this this computation yet it just has an
idea of how it's going to run it so it's
not until we call do compute that it
actually tries to run the
computation
now um all of this is running on our
server and I can't remember what the
medium instance had but the medium
instance has maybe four processors maybe
uh so our server is um so dask is diving
up the work amongst our four processors
on our server for
now now um if we run there if we run
something like a head or a len or
something like that on the data frame
that's also going to run a compute it's
going to trigger a compute um so there
are some functions in the data frame API
which force a compute now we see that
we've got we've got an error and that's
because when we read when we when we ran
the head compute um it gives us an error
on D
types so it says mismatch D types so we
can see that on on these this subset of
columns it has a certain um list of
expected D types but it found
conflicting D types and the reason for
this is because CSV files do not contain
any information about the D types of the
data dask is trying to be lazy so it's
trying to remain lazy and load as little
data as possible possible so what Das
did is it went and it read the first row
of our CSV data and said that must be
the dtype and it turns out desk was
slightly wrong and so so we get this
error um and so if we come on down um we
actually have in our uh data that you
have we actually have the det type
specified in a Json file so if we load
that up and then we rerun our re PSV and
feed Das the D types we can see that we
don't have that error anymore so in
general CSV is not a great format
for well not much of anything if you're
going to be doing things in the with big
data in the cloud um CSV is uh to be
avoided so um we'll see as we go on
we're going to switch over to uh par but
um if you do have to CSV is best to
specify the data types coming
in all right um then you can take a look
at the
columns if You'
like um there's just a lot
of interesting data this is great data
set just to play around with if you just
want some something to mess around with
um okay so let's talk about the logic
behind Das so how is Das going to do
what it does so if I tell um my data
frame I want I want to pull the count so
I just want to count up all the records
um simple simple simple computation here
but it's going to prove the point so
what we get back this object this count
object dask knows that this is going to
be a series it's going to be a dask
series and the result will be one one
partition and it even knows something
about the the the data on there so it
knows uh what the dtype will be and
um but it hasn't actually done any work
yet so the only thing that dask has done
is it has developed a plan to do the
work so if we look at count. visualize
we can see desk's plan which is called
the task
graph and this task graph is dask plan
to do the work now
remember uh forgive the scroll here but
remember when we called our
original um data frame and we saw that
in partitions was seven right even
though we had four months worth of data
so we had four CSV files dask is going
to partition this into seven partitions
so it's going to it's going to divate
out into seven groups of data now if we
take a look at our pass graph we can see
that indeed these seven partitions are
here on the bottom so now what Das is
going to do it's going to to uh divvy up
these individual bits of work these
these tasks onto um well seven workers
if we had worker if we had seven workers
it would divy them onto seven workers
but it will it will distribute that work
onto however many workers that we have
in our dask pool
and so we can see starting from each
individual chunk uh it's going to take
that chunk and get the count for our
individual uh piece of data and it's
going to do that for each partition each
chunk of data and then it's going to
come back and all those will be
aggregated together and then it will
return to
me so again it's not going to do
anything until I call compute so once I
call compute it's actually going to
run the
computation now I'm just going to let
that chug while I keep
talking um any questions so far oh my
gosh lots of questions you back there
for first can we tell back the number of
partitions yes so you can repartition
that data frame however you want okay
yeah thank
you that same question yes um the amount
of work does it depend on
CP you have yes do the amount of workers
depend on the number of CPUs you have so
right now we do not have we didn't set
up a um a specific dask cluster um dask
is just going to use whatever it can
find on your machine so it's kind of
it's doing a lot of work for us by
discovering how many cores we have on
our machine it's going to use those but
um in a minute we'll see how we can
actually set up our cluster
and we will Define how many cores are in
our cluster so the cluster a cluster is
going to be a group of workers that we
send our tasks to so that will be where
we actually run our
compute does that make sense yes okay
any other questions how about what size
in terms of data set you want to use gas
what size data set would I want to use
dask over pandas or Okay um I mean it
just depends on the size of your machine
I was told to stand over
here um it depends on the size of your
machine so obviously once your data set
starts to to fill up your machine Ram
then you need to start
Distributing there some tricks that you
can do you know you can if you didn't
have a cluster and you wanted to stick
with pandas you would have to take for
example one of these CSV files at a time
and process it and sa it out as a subset
you know something like that but um yeah
so the this the point at which you
switch over to using a cluster of
workers is really dependent upon your
machinery and the size of the data and
the size of the cluster that you need
will also depend on the size of your
data ah we lost
one
I don't know what happened to that one p
it back in
again issue this morning in a
room this on the
HDMI here we
go
okay um any more questions yes sorry
about the D types right so what if we
have like thousand columns so how do you
prepare it like is there any other way
we can do
that I mean just specifying each
individual one is the best you know we
just create a Json
and yeah I mean is there a way like we
can find which columns have the
different D types uh when when it says
that there are different like
conflicting D types you're saying you
don't want to specify each individual
column I think you can feed in a
dictionary of Just The Columns that you
want to change oh nice and and like if
if not CSV then what's the most used um
format for the dask it varies widely uh
but I would
say
um uh parquet is common but perhaps the
most common would be something like a
net CDF which is actually going to for
that you would use xarray which is going
to be built on the desk uh array API
which mimics the numpy array API makes
sense thank
you yeah hello thank you very much for
your presentation for introducing us uh
how to use Big Data uh and operate with
it um with um have a question about
using desk so like previously uh in my
experience uh with like other data
frames other tools um with reading par
files
uh I face this problem that sometimes um
by using other libraries um like while I
read paret files um the D types would be
changed automatically and then it's like
mismatching with the original data in uh
in my file um so like for example when I
was using Great Expectations tool um and
I would need to do like run data quality
checks and reading Park file um
asserting D types wouldn't make sense
because like the D types would switch um
is there a way to avoid it with uh using
dask um I saw that like you specify in
Json file creating Library uh creating
um dictionary and just saying this uh
should be this the type and this should
be that the type but that probably would
override what was there uh in original
file how to just read PAR file and um
make sure that D types were not changed
yeah so if you're reading from par um
you you could do the same thing and
specify D types coming in and overwrite
but paret because paret saves the dtype
as part of the saved file
um we'll see in a minute actually where
we're going to read paret files and
we're not going to specify D types so
it's just going to use whatever is
native uh in the save file
questions okay okay all right yeah and I
I uh I I know I'm going kind of quick
through dask because there's a separate
dask tutorial it was this morning I'm
sorry you missed it um or maybe you did
and you learned something I don't know
um it will be on YouTube uh so I'm
trying not to like talk about dask too
much but then also kind of got to talk
about dask because that's part of the
process here so um I apologize if I'm
going kind of quickly through this it's
a lot of material actually this is um a
90minut version of a longer tutorial um
that we have done in the past but we're
we're trying to smoosh it into a smaller
smaller bit here so um going to do my
best um all
right how oh my gosh time is flying
a little bit about partitions um I'm I'm
not going to say too much about this but
the partitions in a Das data frame um
are individual pandas data frames
underneath the Hood um which is why the
API is so similar um it's not
identical uh anyhow um now distributed
computing so up into this point we have
been using the workers um we've been
using the processors that are on your
server
as dask
workers um but what if we want to scale
um
uh the way that we do that is um is by
creating a dask cluster
so um little bit
of definitions here so we have um a
client which is going to be uh the the
python object that we interact with our
cluster that's how we are going to
interact with the cluster the cluster is
going to be um a group of machines this
is going to include a scheduler which is
going to manage how do those tasks in
that task graph get sent to the workers
like how how's that work distributed
amongst the group of workers and the
workers are just individual
machines now um because we are operating
in the cloud we are going to use another
tool called Das Gateway and Das Gateway
is going to provide
um uh an interface for us to create a
kubernetes cluster of cloud uh servers
so um these these servers these worker
nodes may have so each worker node may
have its own individual uh scheduler or
we may just have um a worker node with
several processors on it so that may
have
um I don't want to get into too much of
this details
but um just know that Das Gateway is
what is managing our Cloud cluster of
worker nodes and a worker is just going
to be a machine it's just a a a a cloud
a cloud machine at this point and um and
then we're going to have a Schuler
that's going to distribute that work out
to the to the individual
workers so let's let's create a cluster
so this is
um
uh how we're going to set up our cluster
we're going to feed it
um some options so we have since we're
working in a Jupiter notebook we have a
couple of different options this uh this
uh environment is a conduit environment
so when you when you have all your
workers and you're going to send this
this this do compute out to each
individual workers you have to actually
specify what is the conduit environment
that's that's going to
run um and so here we have a list of all
the environments that we have on on this
navari instance right now um but you
guys already have hopefully the right on
selected which is analyst Pi dat NYC
2023 and then we're going to ask for a
medium worker so the other thing that we
can specify um during the nabari
configuration setup is exactly what size
workers do we want so um here we're just
going to use the medium worker again and
then also we can pass environment
variables to our workers because
um uh our our workers don't have the
same file system that we have that we're
sitting on so not only do we have to
send our data to the workers and our
workers have to have an environment to
work in um but our workers might need
access to like um S3 for example so um
so you may need to send it environment
variables now we're going to create a
new
cluster and we see the um we have a
cluster widget here so we can either
adapt manually or I mean we can either
scale manually or adapt use adaptive
scaling so the manual scaling is when we
will say hey dask I need 10 workers I
want you to go out and get those Cloud
worker machines I don't want you to keep
them until I tell you to let them go um
but you can imagine that's not super
efficient and we try to be judicious
with our uh compute clusters or compute
resources so we like to do um adaptive
scaling so you set a minimum and a
maximum usually like if I was working on
something like for real I would set the
minimum to be zero and then the maximum
to be like whatever the maximum um uh
number of workers that my compute needed
um but for this example so that we can
all kind of start asking for workers
because it's going to take some time um
we're going to set a minimum of five and
a maximum of 10 and you're going to
click adapt and it's going to start to
request those
nodes now we're going to get ourselves a
we're going to connect that cluster to a
client
now um we get a dashboard URL here so if
you click on this dashboard URL that
takes us
to that takes us to the dask
dashboard um the other option you have
is um on this nabari deployment we
have the dask
um um dup
uh where did the word go Jupiter lab
extension so if we can paste in the URL
of our worker and if you have spaces on
the end of your url it won't work it's
kind of finicky um so just make sure you
don't have any spaces back behind status
and this gives you um the same thing
that you see in the dashboard you can
click on these and get them inside of
your um um Jupiter
lab
uh
interface so now I can like stick this
down here at the
bottom and we can keep an eye on it I
also like cluster map so this is cluster
map kind of shows you how many nodes
that you
have
um yeah okay I'm just going to keep on
trucking uh we have a quick computation
here
yeah
um yeah I think I think I'm just going
to kind of run through this example
because we have a lot of stuff to
cover um so if we calculate the maximum
distance and run a compute on this I
just want to talk about the dashboard
for just a second
um we can see that the cluster map will
start to add additional nodes as dask
feels the need for more nodes to handle
that compute desk will start to add more
nodes and then we can see what's
actually happening here this node in the
middle is the scheduler and these uh
nodes around the outside are worker
nodes and so we see data being
transferred back and forth um we didn't
need very many nodes obviously that was
an easy that was an easy one um we also
see that this this task
stream
um
and
yeah um okay so we
saw I'm going to run that one more time
and I'm going to switch over to this Das
D dashboard dask dashboard um so we can
also see through this interface we can
see the bite stored per workers this is
how much um worker memory is being used
and uh here we if we watch this you
start to see that your workers are
filling up um with memory if they once
your workers start to get full of memory
that's when you want to start scaling
more so you need to add more workers at
that
point
um you can also access the task graph
here through this
interface
um yeah all right well let's keep going
because there's more stuff on the next
notebook um
all
right
okay okay um so now we're going to
actually um work with some bigger data
all right so for now we're going to run
our dask uh Gateway object again and
um this time um we're going to do we're
going to create our cluster
programmatically so you don't have to
use the the widgets if you don't want to
um we can do all the same things
programmatically so if we run this
and um one thing to note is even though
we specified adapt here and we gave it a
minimum and a maximum it's going to do
that it's going to adapt but it's not
going to show up the five and the 10
here in the in widget you just got you
just got to trust it just trust all
right so now um you see our our cluster
map down here our widgets at the bottom
didn't populate that's because we have a
new URL so we have to take our URL and
repopulate here and make sure you delete
the spaces at the
end and our widgets will update
okay now we are going to read the full
data set which has been resaved as par
so part of the very first part of this
process um or working with this data is
we took the CSV files we assigned some D
types and we saved it back out as par so
that we had a data set that was a little
easier to work with so now if we have um
uh if we call read parquet on this
data
um we can see it's this the same same
data as we had
before now
uh I'm going to I'm going to run this
actually I don't have enough real
estate goodness okay
um all
right so when I run this so this let me
just say what what are we running uh
we're doing a group by flight date so
we're going to group by flight date
flight date we're going to pull out the
the the canceled column and we're going
to get a count and then we're going to
plot it with HV plot more on HV plot
later um but um just to kind of look at
this just really briefly um this is
going to take a long time to compute um
and we're going to see that when we get
a result our plot looks kind of crummy
and the reason why is because um HV plot
has received all of this data from all
the different chunks out of order so
this is your your your typical it's
trying to plot a line plot but all of
the chunks came back out of order and
so um so what we're going to do is we're
going to have to um we're going to have
to sort the data before we plot it but
something like um sorting uh setting the
index those things are uh data set wise
processes so these require something
called shuffling so we have all of this
data that's distributed across all these
workers um and the only way to figure
out for example a sort the only way to
sort something is to actually touch all
of the data there's just no way around
it so whenever you're working with
distributed computing um you want to
minimize the shuffling of data so
usually what we do is if you have to if
you have to do that as part of your part
of your workflow you do that once and
you either save it or or persist it on
disk so um here we have uh already
sorted the data so this is the sorted
version of this data and we're going to
save it out so that the pre the next uh
couple of computations are going to run
a little bit
smoother do I have until 2:30 is that
what it
is yes okay question yes um are you
saying that um if you sort your data and
save dat the data it will be fast it
won't
reshuffle it will Shuffle it right it
will Shuffle it but then you have to you
have to save that state exactly either
save it to a file or or uh persist it on
disk which we're going to talk about
persisting things persisting data on the
cluster here in a second okay
all
right so now rerun this uh previous
computation on the sorted data set I'm
going to go ahead and do this because I
I need to talk faster there's this is
this is a lot of information so now if
we if we rerun um that same computation
on the sorted data set um it goes a lot
faster we see a lot less um a lot less
little red bars so in our task stream
where you see red that's actually the
nodes communicating with each other so
the when we distribute the work amongst
uh multiple workers those workers have
to talk to each other right they have to
reaggregate that
information okay now persisting data yes
I knew we were going to get there
um so um like we said there are some
tasks that you do that are
computationally expensive and we don't
want to we don't want to recompute for
example um reading the data and
transferring that data from wherever it
lives onto your cluster is going to take
a lot of time so just data transfer on
the reads um is timec
consuming so um one thing that you might
want to do is persist the data on your
cluster so you have your group of worker
nodes you want to read the data dask is
going to distribute that data onto your
onto your worker nodes and you're going
to persist so you call like dot persist
it is uh in
desk and
um desk will actually leave that data on
the nodes so as we saw our our cluster
map um and our cluster memory um as we
ran this computation dask was reading
data it was doing some computation to
some small subset of the data and it was
letting that data go as it reaggregated
and sent the result to us but we can
also tell dask when you read the data
and you do some stuff and you send some
information back to me I want you to
hold on to that data like don't let it
go and so we do that um with
persistence
um I apparently I have examples here who
knew who knew can't keep up with myself
so if we
run these
two aggregations so we Group by flight
date and pull out departure delay we're
going to count the total number of
departure delays by
date and we'll compute the arrival
delays by date this is without
persistence so what dask is
doing let me find
this
just go right
here right
so what dask is doing is it's going to
run this
compute bring all the information back
together and then um once it has that
information and it just just runs all
the compute and sends it back to me it's
going to let all that information go so
now all of that data has has been
essentially purged from our
cluster all right so that took us where
were we uh
25 seconds for one 23 seconds for
another now if we took
part
sorry if we took this data set and um we
persisted this data now what we're doing
is we're going to take all of our data
and we're going to put it on our nodes
and we're just leave it there so what
we'll see is it's going in gathering up
data and our workers are filling up so
here's the number of workers that we
have and slowly um these numbers are
creeping up as we store data on our
worker um okay now if we run the same uh
compute We Run The those same two
computations now we see that it only
took us 2.7 seconds and 1.67 seconds
because all the data didn't have to be
reread because reading data from disk
and transferring it to another Cloud
Server is the most timec consuming part
of
this um okay now a little bit about
partitioning you know I'm going to skip
over this partitioning bit um right now
we have
641 um partitions we can re organize our
data by partitioning it differently so
this is like um telling dask exactly how
many uh bit how many chunks of data uh
to to separate into before we send it to
the cluster I'm going to let you guys do
that on your
own we also have a meta keyword I'm just
going to Breeze through this because I
want to get to visualization stuff and I
talked about D too much I knew that was
going to happen um I also give give a a
whole workshop on dask and xray so I
have a lot to say but um but I want to
get to visualization so um there's also
a uh a meta keyword here um which helps
us to um helps us to help dask predict
so kind of the same situation where D
types um with the D types dask tries its
best to make an assumption but there are
some cases where dask just doesn't have
enough information to to make a good
prediction and so we can send it
metadata um in this case we're telling
it hey I want you to I I want you to um
I want you to know this is going to be a
panda series once it's done um okay so
let let's move on to
visualizations it's much more
fun all right so um our big data
visualizations here let me minimize that
real quick
it's just not enough
space okay
um
um yep
okay
so for our visualization we're going to
use a tool called HV plot and um HV plot
is part of the Hol Suite of tools and
they give us some interactive
visualizations both in the
um in the notebook here and just uh in
like web apps or things like that um and
it can be backed by either b or matap
plot lib or plotly and um and so H HV
plot is uh kind of a simplified version
of Hol views and what HV plot does is it
kind of mimics the The Dot Plot function
it that pandas has so if you're familiar
with pandas and you've ever done a Dot
Plot and it gives you a quick
visualization HV plot is going to be
something
similar um so super high level API and
it's uh it's currently built on on these
data libraries so it works with Das data
frames xray pandas geopandas all those
that you see
here um
so if if
we get ourselves a
cluster and this little snippet just um
if you already had a cluster running in
your other notebook and didn't shut it
down um this will go and grab that
cluster and if not it'll it'll create a
new
one um but if you do if you did have a
already running cluster that it connects
to um sometimes you have to refresh your
dask uh dashboard page
all right so going back to our flights
data
um uh small caveat here we're taking
some subsets
because all of this all of these HB plot
examples that we're going to see here
will work if you have a very large
cluster but this is a huge data set and
so um we're going to take a small subset
of the data set uh so that we can all
run this on 10 worker
nodes but feel free to adapt uh so now
we're going to filter by year so we're
going to um filter to greater than 2020
and we're also going to f filter by um
the carrier name so American Airlines
united I don't know what WN is and
Delta all right
so now if we want to
look see what's
happening why is that not loing
okay oh H I don't have any
workers that's why that's taking a long
time I probably shouldn't have shut down
my
cluster yeah so one thing like just like
when we were spinning up nodes at the
beginning of class um gcp is like it
only wants to give out a certain number
workers at a time it's almost like rate
limiting you on workers uh to a degree
um so sometimes I find that when I teach
these classes I have a hard time getting
workers back which is why I put that
little thing in there where you keep
your cluster alive um but I don't have
any workers so I can't actually do any
work I might have to invite somebody up
on up to the stage who knows we'll give
it a minute questions
questions questions
no I don't know why I'm not getting
workers does anybody else getting
workers you guys have work
workers yeah at least
one
mm all
right yes when you are
partitioning data is is there a method
to partitioning different types of data
namely you know there's calculated data
then I'm thinking
of of text but you know long lengthy
text yeah
so that's there's a complicated answer
there um so right now we're just working
with the dash data frame API which is
going to partition based on
rows um if you're using the dask
array um the interface and you have a
dask array so you have a
multi-dimensional array then instead of
partitioning it's called chunking so
you're chunking in
multi-dimensions which then gets a lot
more complicated so then um I could talk
for an hour on chunking how to chunk
data but it it's very specific to um to
what data you have so if you have time
series data and you're going to be doing
like time series computations you want
your your um chunks to follow along with
the your time series like a series of uh
like a Time series at a given
node uh like on grided data for example
if you have grided data and you have a
Time series for each individual node on
the grid you're going to want to chunk
so that each grid node uh has all the
time series at at that grid node in a
single chunk I don't know if I explain
that well I I it I like it than it's it
CH chunking is like you could spend
forever on chunking because that it the
efficiency of how you read and write
your data and compute on your data has a
lot to do with how you
chunk and the data frame interface is a
little simplified because it's based on
pandas so it's just partitioning based
on rows
yeah and I have no idea why I'm not
getting anything so I'm just going to
restart because
Jupiter Jupiter
is like you know sometimes you just just
start
over actually you know what I'm going to
do I'm going to force it to give me a
new
cluster hold on
oops start fresh
give me a new
cluster close this out
I'm not sure what is happening right
now
well so I'm wondering if if somebody
else wants to come share their
screen why I can't I have no idea why I
can't get a cluster
running
goodness what do you
do patient does anybody want to come
share the screen does anybody you
refresh the window this one the other
one back
oh I could yeah because sometimes you're
in
a it gives a command then it won't go
talk to the if you know what I
mean I don't think it's like I don't
know what's happening right now
honestly feel like I just I just want to
restart which is like that's that's
that's my only
fix come
on so if I
say list
clusters so I have a cluster
pool so executed everything before the
cluster it says I have a cluster pool
let me just
see it's so it's created the cluster
pool but I don't have any workers in my
pool so for some reason dask I mean not
dask gcp does not want to give me any
workers they're on to
me how many work are you want I
specified um through the through the API
well actually
um yeah right now I'm just getting uh
actually what I can do it's a good point
well we have 9 minutes left
and I there's a lot of stuff here but I
can't actually visualize
[Music]
it oh my
goodness yeah I would love to use your
computer thank
you
we have half an
hour we have half an we don't have half
an hour do we have half an
hour 250 oh
gosh
okay um I feel better now
okay here we go
um the coloring is very funky and I'm
not sure
why I think I'm just going to I'm just
we'll just we'll be all right we'll be
all right I think it's
okay I'm not sure how to change the
coloring on the
display
um okay
okay all right uh so now we are going to
put HV plot on top of desk so we kind of
saw the same visualization a second ago
um where we're going to group by the
flight date and capture um the total
number of departure delays based on the
date so if we take a look at this we
just put do plot back here and HV plot
is going to um is going
to uh look at what type of data we have
and it's going to make its best guess as
to what style so it's gonna it's gonna
look at the data and say okay I'm gonna
plot that with a line plot um this is a
fun data set because you can like you
can really see um a lot of very strange
things if we plotted 2020 you could
actually see the drop off uh when Co
everything shut down um I'm going to
skip over this part I'm going to skip
the the your turn business cuz I we took
enough time with that um but here we are
going to
um we are going to calculate the mean of
the arrival delay based on the day of
the
week and we're going to um put that on a
scatter plot so all we have to do is we
have to call do scatter here and then
we're going to tell HV plot to put day
of the week on the x- axis and arrival
delay on the Y AIS and we can look
there's a link here to the HV plot
Gallery
um
uh you know I did that now I'm not sure
how to get back command s open
open
come sweet thanks all right so you can
you can look through the hvv plot
gallery to see what different um plot
types they have um so one of the really
great things about HV plot is that you
can get widgets to lay on top of your um
on top of your uh visualizations or to
link up with your visualizations very
simple very in a very simple uh way so
here we're going to create a
histogram and we're going to group by so
this group by is telling HV plot um that
I want a widget and I want a widget
based on this op carrier so it's
essentially doing in the background it's
essentially doing a panda's group bu but
it's going to give us a widget to
interact
with so do we persist this data
anywhere probably oh we did persist okay
good so
what it's going to do is it's going to
um uh HV plot knows how to interact with
the Das data frame and it's going to do
its best job to run its computations um
in the lazy fashion as much as possible
but it is going to have to run some
computes so um just like we talked about
like if you run a head on a dash data
frame it's got to run a compute in order
to actually return some data and so the
same thing with HV plot HV plot at some
point is going to run a compute and so
we'll see that it does a compute um for
every uh carrier so here uh if we change
our carrier so it gave us a free widget
so we get a free widget that's connected
to our um our visualization here which
is interactive um and but when we change
the carrier we see that it's going to
rerun our compute and so when we create
visualizations based on
um uh uh Dash data frames we need to
think about uh
exactly how is uh how that data is
persisted on the cluster and what's the
best way to store the data so that our
um we do minimal
recomputes um as we interact with the
visualization so it's sort of the the
good and the bad right so HV plot gives
us Interactive uh components to our
visualization but then also um it's
interactive so how much do we
pre-compute ahead of
time um all right another great thing
about HV plot we can compose uh and
overlay plots so we can have multiple
plots that are linked together so I'm
going to run this
and I'm going to persist this data so so
here we're getting our subset we're
going to do a group by for um day of the
week and op carrier we're going to pull
out departure delay and then we're going
to aggregate it uh in three different
ways this is just the same as uh pandas
doag right we're just going to aggregate
it based on the minimum the the mean and
the
maximum and
then um a little note about the rest of
this um this is like a uh two two
commands that you don't want want to
have to do very often so reset index is
computationally expensive because it has
to touch all of the data s values is
computationally expensive because you
have to touch all the data but at the
moment Das data frames does not support
multi-indices so what's coming back from
everything on this
side everything on that side um is a
multi-indexed data frame but because um
desk doesn't quite
doesn't work with that just yet we're
going to reset the index and then we're
going to sort values so that our
visualization looks
nice and then once we do all that we're
going to persist the data because we
don't want to do that multiple
times so here we're going to get a
minmax plot so we're going to plot um an
area
plot so we're going to have day of the
week here on the x- axis and then on the
Y AIS we we actually have two y AIS um
or two things um visualized on the y-
axis we have uh the minimum and the
maximum and then um we specify our Alpha
so this is
um you know your
opacity and we're going to give
ourselves a free widget so Group by
carrier um and then we can also uh this
HV plot area we can either stack them or
unstack them we can provide a Legend
um an excellent question uh that no one
asked yet is where is my
Legend I have the same question see me
after
class all right um so here we composed
this this area plot we have a widget
that if if we change our carrier here we
interact with our uh widget our visual
will automatically update great now
supposing we had another um
oops
another
plot and here we're going to plot uh
just a scattered plot we're going to
give a day of the week uh on the x-axis
and the mean for the for the Y AIS and
we're going to do the same thing with
our widget we're going to group by op
carrier for our widget so now we have
another
visualization and we but we have the
same widget all right if we use the plus
operator for HV plot what we what that
will do for us is it will plot those two
plots side by
side and the other
thing we're just going have to minimize
here so you can see okay so if we use
plus that will plot um multiple plots
side by side but then also notice that
we just got one widget so hvv plot
understands it was able to understand
that we have the same widget that's
trying to access or controlling our
visualization so it combined them so now
this one single widget is going to
control both of those
plots we also can provide this
um uh star operator and that will tell
HV plot to Overlay the two
visualizations so now we're going to
Overlay our minimum and our
maximum um what were we looking at I
don't even know
anymore departure delay depth delay
depart goly okay so now we can overlay
these two together so we see the the
absolute minimum uh departure delay for
the B for the uh day of the week um to
the maximum departure delay for this
Delta Carrier uh so we can see there's a
pretty big range of departure delay I
mean at some point you're it's not a
delay anymore it's just canceled um
which we have data for uh but but it
that doesn't really tell us much so
let's overlay the mean and we can
actually get an idea of where the mean
actually lies which is a whole lot
closer to the bottom here and then it's
interactive so we can actually play
around um I was really surprised to know
that planes leave early um according to
this
data I
don't you got me but um
anyway uh all right moving on um so it
kind of we've kind of gone over uh
different ways to create these HV plots
now there's um you can go look through
the the docks for HV plot to see what
sort of uh parameters you have uh
available to mess with um uh for example
the the alpha or the color or things
like that or the other thing that um HV
plot provides is this Explorer um
interface so Explorer is a gooey
interface for constructing your plots so
um say you just wanted to uh you didn't
feel like looking through the docks and
just wanted to mess around with how to
um how to generate your plots you have
this little
um this little Explorer goey and this
helps you to
Define
um it it you can Define your plot
through this
interface so you can specify what do you
want on each um X and Y you can group
Group by you can specify the the type of
plot
um and um you can see the the default
plot was a mess uh right so um I don't
know um so you can play around with all
the different options that are available
in HV plot without having to know
exactly what plot options are available
at any given moment um so this is just
kind of fun to play around with and sort
of build your own um
as you go uh I will say you can get
yourself into a a bit of a pickle here
um because you are
doing uh buy and group buy or group buy
operations underneath the hood group buy
gives you a widget buy does the same
thing it does a group bu but it doesn't
give you a widget um and so because it's
doing that kind of compute on the back
end you can uh end up crashing your
kernel because you've tried to compute
too much um so we've we've sort of run
this on a on a subset um but just be
aware uh when you're when you're playing
with this and you're try trying to build
your graph it's best to do it on a
smaller subset um and then when you're
done um you
can um you can save your
plot or you can generate the code for
that plot so now you've got your you've
got your plot looking just like you want
it you can either save this plot out or
you can click on code and go and grab
the actual code that you would need to
recreate that
plot it's pretty fun oh look at
that that this is my fault right here
um I neglected to add one of
these sorry uh your cond environment
that I gave you is missing a package um
so you can't save but you
can see I could just add that I could
add to the cond environment really quick
and then we could
all
um oh I wonder if this
will oops so the good thing about nabari
is that um no that doesn't
work the good thing about nabari is that
we can all share a created cond
environment the bad thing is if somebody
changes the environment and doesn't tell
you you all don't have it
um oh goodness all right um let's talk
about geographic
plots um really briefly
here
um all right so now uh we're going to
steal this this
CSV uh file here it's not stealing they
shared it they meant for us to have it
um but it's uh it's lud longitude
locations of US airports and we're going
to combine that with our flights
data um so this is what the data looks
like uh so the all of the airports have
these airport codes and we're going to
combine that with our flights data um to
get latitude longitude for um for our
flight we're going to persist that on
our
cluster
and um and
now if we run
umhb plot.
points we can um get a visualization of
that data backed by um a geographic map
so this is using a web map towel service
back behind our image so we tell it
longitude our longitude column is going
to be X latitude column is going to be Y
and then when we say go equals true
that's um that's letting HV plot know
that this is a geographic data set so it
knows it's going to be plotting latitude
and longitude so um the visualization
here is not uh skewed it's reprojected
properly so that um we get our typical
what we would typically expect uh from a
map um and then the other thing we can
do we can specify tiles so there are
variety of web map to services that are
available um I I like carto light is a
good one
um if you're doing visualizations and
you don't want to mess with the colors
So like um you know sometimes color can
uh you don't want a colored background
if you're going to be examining your
color map
um right uh so we can specify our color
map is uh based on departure delay and
we can give it xlm and Y Lim for the
initial
visualization and this little button
here um all of our plots are backed by
bouquet um though if you wanted a matte
plot lib or a plotly uh image you can
also use that um back end um but in book
K land uh this little circular guy will
reset your plot to the original extents
so that would be whatever xlm and ym are
being set
for all
right
lastly
um
lastly plotting large data sets so all
of this has been PL plotting large data
sets
but we've thus far we've done this in
such a way that we've used um dask to
sort of pre-process a lot of our Big
Data before we got it to
um before we got it to visualization but
what if you have a lot of data and you
want to send a lot of data to your
visualization to be visualized um so
here we are going to use um data
Shader um I'm not sure why I would read
okay so our full data set has 125
million rows so for this data set we're
going to I me for this example I'm just
going to pull in a subset but if you
want to use this this bigger data set
you certainly can um you're probably
going to need more nodes for that
um but you know gcp has to give you
those um but anyway uh so we can run all
of these visualizations on the full data
set it's just for a matter of time and
number of worker nodes uh we've down
sampled a little bit just so you know
all right so what data Shader does data
Shader is also in the Hol is sweet
although it can be it's it's built and
maintained by the same folks um at
Anaconda uh great people by the way um
but it also um it can be applied outside
of the H Suite but for us um it's a
first class citizen in the HV plot API
so here if we want to
um do a line chart and we want to have
um flight date on the x-axis and
departure delay on the Y AIS that's
actually going to be a lot of data right
so we have 30 million rows and the the
uh in order
to visualize 30 million rows of of data
if you send all that data to the browser
your browser will crash because your
browser just simply cannot handle that
amount of data so what data Shader does
is it's going to downsample the data
before it gets to your browser so um our
visualization our image that we're going
to create is a certain size some some
pixel by pixel size so it's you know 600
pixel pixels by 800 pixels what data
Shader is going to do is it's going to
downsample the data at each individual
pixel so um it's it's going to
aggregate uh what would have been behind
that pixel and it's going to aggregate
based on a variety of different methods
so you can either tell it to aggregate
based on the the total number of counts
um or you can aggregate based on the
mean um that's taking a
while
so um so the only amount the so the
total amount of data that gets sent to
the browser is then only the size of the
actual image the total number of pixels
uh so all of the work is being done on
the python side behind the scenes and we
only have to send a smaller amount of
data to the
browser while that's thinking see do you
see how many um Red Blocks we have in
our task stream it's doing a lot of uh
transferring so each red block is a
transfer um either between nodes or
between the node and the
scheduler um and anytime you see a lot
of those um that's kind of a warning
sign that uh you're not doing things
very efficiently so it's spending a lot
of time talking it's spending a lot of
time in communication and transferring
data
um I'm also not really sure why is it
still
thinking um oh I know
why uh because as we pan and zoom it's
going to have to rerender um more on
that a sec um okay so what this has done
is um it has plotted our 30 million row
data set all on a single plot so now we
have every single data point is on that
plot but what we've done is we've
downsampled it so that um the only thing
that actually came to the browser was
the color of the pixel um so the color
of the pixel was based
on um the uh aggregation of the data uh
on the back end so that was done by
python so we can also do this with a
scatter plot
and um and then lastly um we have some
different options for how we aggregate
the data uh so we can either aggregate
based on the oops based on the mean the
count min max and more
uh so here if we just change our
aggregator we can see we get another
um uh option I this is a different plot
but we're just doing a scatter a scatter
plot um with a different
[Applause]
aggregator